to the
Oh
good morning how are you
now trying to test it wasn't it how many
of you go to church by the way dear it's
interesting isn't it I was brought up in
Liverpool and my brother's here now
there are seven of us in the family and
we used to go to church in a place
called the Foursquare temple which was
just up the street from where we lived
and the reason we went there was the
nearest church to our house that was the
extent of our theological commitment it
was the the nearest church to the house
and we thought why would you go past
that church to do it another one
it's like going past Tesco's yet to
Waitrose we thought and I used to go
there say there were seven of us but
when I was a kid I was extraordinarily
cute it's hard to convey this ready
until I was four what thank you man
thank you remember that was meant to be
quicker to remember
half price if you're late no till I was
four
my dad was convinced that I was going to
be a football player in fact my brother
John who was here right now became a
football player and so did my brother
Neal they were both taken on by Everson
and but until I was four I was I was the
fit one at you you weren't born at the
time so it did give me an advantage I
have to say but it's a small genetic
head start and then yeah my dad just
took me to the park and and I would find
my way home eventually the law was
different then and and eventually he was
convinced that I was the one I was very
fast muscular very attractive as a child
and and then in 1954 there was this
polio epidemic do you embrace anybody
major epidemic you can read all about it
and I got it I got polio at the age of
four and that pretty much put an end to
my career with Everton as I couldn't
walk properly and was actually paralyzed
for eight months so it's a ruled out my
chance of getting in the team it
wouldn't now by the way I think
I think there'd be some excitement about
to put the name forward for Everton at
the moment but my dad was Derek you know
obviously devastated as was my mother
you know and I mean I'm recovered you
know I was in hospital for eight months
and then and I recovered and I came out
of hospital looking extremely cute I was
wearing two calipers I was I had a
wheelchair crutches long curly hair
blonde hair and a lisp come on Helen
people approach me spontaneously in the
street to give me money they did that
was that was that cute and in fact my
brother and I used to exploit that not
John but my brother Ian and I by
mingling among the football crowds in
Liverpool where I would strategically
fall over in front of somebody which
would double the donation normally Ian
is yet to pay me my part achieve this
this particular scam but we stood to the
church and it was the Foursquare temple
which turns out to be a an American
evangelical church you look it up and it
was actually the old Methodist chapel in
our street but it was founded by a woman
called Aimee Semple McPherson and if
you've ever heard of it you should check
her out if you haven't she was a one of
the first superstar evangelicals she was
American and she used to fill out church
every Sunday three times a day with
about 3,000 people and I mean all the
old movie stars went to see and she sent
out these missionaries across the planet
to bring the Forsberg gospel to
underprivileged families all around the
world and one of them turned up in our
street which is why we went there rather
than to Tesco's and I used to like going
we used to have
they eventually I stayed on when my
brother stopped going because I couldn't
have a good reason not to and I didn't
like to let people down you know and I
got on with them all right and they let
me take communion a sort of communion
you know a an evangelical type communion
we used to they didn't have wine you
know if you're if you're a Catholic so
if you're madly inborn Catholics if you
go to communion you can often get a
decent clarity
you know it's worth turning up you know
you might get a decent vintage just a
tip don't go up all of it that's just a
thought you know it tends to dissipate
the congregation if you finish the
entire cup but I can hang on to the
Prius begging for more of it it's not
not a good sign
not a clear signal of your Redemption
frankly but 10 and also in place so we
didn't have red wine we had Ribena and
in place of unleavened bread we had
nimble
that little squares of nimble white
little bread so I form a pretty dim view
of the saviours Constitution as a child
frankly take this this is my blood
really this is my body are you certain
no you need help that's all I can tell
you below you need urgent medical
attendants but I kept going anyways and
eventually we moved from the area and I
stopped going but I kept going because I
didn't want to let them down but it
became a bit of a drag after a while the
turning point for me was when I was told
I had a chat with one of the the
teachers in the class and Sunday school
and she got to the point where she said
that if you're not saved you won't go to
heaven you don't go to church you don't
go to heaven I said really and I was
desperate trying to be saved as a kid
you know you're lying in bed because I
was told all I had to do was ask so I
kept asking and the line was engaged but
as far as I could tell but the turning
point was that I said well hang on I
just thought I thought I got my dad
doesn't go to church is he going to
heaven and I remember the teacher
fumbled for a bit you know came out with
a form of words and I said yes yes but I
mean a lot of conditional clauses in
there and even at the age of 11 I was
suspicious of you know of the
subjunctive
sir so I said yeah but is he going or
not and she said well if he doesn't go
to church we'd not say no he won't go to
heaven I said and therefore one so we go
to hell she said after the long night
had worn on at this point but so I made
up my mind at that point I thought this
is either nonsense or I'm going with him
if it's good enough and I want to be
there you know frankly now I would like
to say that my views on religion matured
beyond this point they happened frankly
they happened and which is not to say I
do not have a deep interest in spiritual
things which I do but I've always been
myself at a distance from organised
religions
I don't recommending that I'm just
saying this was the case well what
happened was that some years later my
mum ran into this teacher in the street
I she wasn't driving a car at a time
shooter took us some time to pinpoint
her in the middle of the road but she
got her
good wasn't easy no but she ran into it
and she said there's a great woman at
you she said to my mum how's your
Kenneth doing and she said it was great
I was teaching the University of Warwick
at the time and she said he's great he's
a teacher work University she said you
know he was always a great inspiration
to us I'm a mum said who are Kenneth we
caught the right one and she said yes he
said because he kept coming to the
church every Sunday we'd see him
strutting down the street and I pulled
on his crutches and there we'll monster
where we thought we'd have to close the
church because of the slow are the low
congregations and it was the sight of
him turning up every week that kept the
place open and I thought how ironic is
that because I was lying in bed of a
night praying for it to close
and I've never quite got over this idea
that we are all to some degree is the
author of our own fate and they'd only
look around properly we could
reconstruct situations that we feel
where the victim are but which we are
actually personally creating and I think
this is true in a spiritual sense as
well and some were last year year and a
half ago do you care when this was how
important is it to that I get this state
right I mean I can google it now if it
matters take my word for it this
happened September of 2009 Terry my wife
and I is here today were at the there's
a fantastic event called the vancouver
peace summit and the peace summit was
about 2,000 people it was organized by
the Dalai Lama Center in Vancouver and I
had to moderate the opening session
there about 2,000 people and the panel
was amazing it was Pierre Omidyar
General him he's the founder of eBay
which was a good idea
wasn't it
I was really close I had D Bey you know
like that close Pierre got eBay and
matthieu ricard to know of him he's a
French the richer French cell biologists
well he was original baby but originally
from being honest but it became a French
salvos but he became a Tibetan monk his
father was a philosopher and he said
these have all these people come into
the house all the time when he was a kid
is a very prominent philosopher his
father and he said we know we had Samuel
Beckett come to the house and Albert
Camus this great raft of French
intellectuals used to come to the house
and have dinner with them and he said it
was heavy you know they had John Paul
Sartre came and seemed under Beauvoir he
said we were in the thick of French
intellectual life and as a kid he was
invited to join the tables he said but
he realized was something about it it
never quite struck him until he saw a
film or a news report of some Tibetan
monks who showed up in Paris and he said
they looked incandescent ly happy he
said it was like seeing some of the
prophets you know come back from ancient
times and sitting over their robes and
long hair he said they were exuding the
sense of happiness
he said whereas all these intellectuals
going to tears were as neurotic as you
could imagine anybody to be you know
there were the smartest people in the
Western tradition but they looked
completely wrapped with uncertainty and
anxiety and smoking themselves to death
and you're drinking vast amounts of
booze and pronouncing on the principles
of a good life and he said I wasn't
completely inclined to their view
frankly so he went off to Tibet and
joined the monastery and he's been a
monk now for over thirty years and he's
been a close associate of the Dalai Lama
and also he was he's taken part in all
kinds of research into the effects of
meditation on the brain you know that
Alan I was actually very interested in
the science of meditation so matthieu
ricard is matyoo do the French for you
Matthew is officially recognized now as
the happiest person on earth
honestly that must be a burden muscle it
socially mostly you can't show up
anywhere and be miserable you know
people get you under the trays
description act I mean what's this you
know yeah run it down in the street and
you have to smile and say this is great
imma say that's great
unfold - - who's Desmond Tutu his
daughter who's living in his tradition
she's also a cleric in South Africa
doing wonderful work to do with women in
South Africa
I can't toll a on the platform you know
his work he wrote a book called the
power of now
fantastic book so that's the panel plus
the Dalai Lama
that's the panel and I'm having to
moderate this conversation and introduce
it one of my first problems was I had to
introduce the Dalai Lama you know I mean
Morgenthau thought she had a problem
introducing me you know but frankly it's
a pushover I thought what you say about
the Dalai Lama and then I thought I
don't need to say anything do I
so anybody whose name starts with thee
your home and dry aren't you ready thank
you
you've managed to seek the definite
article in genome I think frankly which
Dalai Lama will I be introducing that
would be the Dalai Lama anyway we had
this the session was called world peace
through personal peace that's the theme
about two thousand people and an hour to
sort this one out and so we were just
killing time to the final 20 minutes
frankly what should we talk about now
having sorted that on it and but the
Dalai Lama said lots of wonderful things
he does one of the things that that
happened he said somebody asked him a
question not in the session I was
moderating but the one that followed it
but it was being moderated by Mary
Robinson all the sessions were moderated
my people call Robinson really matter
that's the only qualification and he's
wearing his way through the alphabet at
the moment he retired about five years
time and we get to X's but suddenly
asked him a question Mayor Rahm said
you're holding the signal and what do
you think of this and he thought you
know from for about a minute you know he
kind of leant forward we all mentally
leant forward to towards him all $2,000
thinking this is going to be great it's
the Dalai Lama chat indiscretion and he
paused and we waited for what we know is
going to be something sensational and
and then he said I don't know well we
were taken aback
you know we thought what do you mean you
don't know Minya you're the Dalai Lama I
mean we don't know but you're supposed
to know but what was wonderful about it
was it was a real moment of permission
for the whole room because his point was
and he talked a bit about it later on is
that he said what he said what is that I
don't know I haven't thought about that
and this point was that he doesn't want
to say you knows things he doesn't know
I just thought about it now I thought
about a lot of stuff not that I was on a
panel later on with him with a physicist
wouldn't Nobel Prize Lee he was talking
in the brief
he was speaking to Matthew and he said
you know what would the Dalai Lama think
of Pascale and Matthew said he would
know anything about Pascale you know
he's he's the world's one of those
leading scholars of Buddhism he doesn't
claim to know everything in the Western
philosophical tradition or Western
literature and I just thought it was
wonderful of him said I don't know
because in our culture not to know is to
be at fault socially isn't it you people
pretend to know lost things they don't
know because the worst thing to do is
appear to be uninformed about something
to not have an opinion you know now and
use me to fuel that idea you know they
bring people on for instant opinions
about things they don't know about and I
feel this particularly because I work a
lot in education an education is filled
with people politically who pronounce on
education who know nothing about it I
can think of one example as we speak
Michael Gove I'm thinking of any place
and as you're wondering what I'm talking
about so I think that's important that
we should know the limits of our
knowledge and understand what we don't
know and be willing to explore things we
don't know without feeling embarrassed
not knowing about it but it also said
something very interesting which
connected to some work John my brother's
doing John is putting together our
family tree at the moment in the woods
one of the differences we were born into
a big working-class family in Liverpool
and one of the differences I think
between working-class families and
middle-class families of long standing
is that for the mill or upper-middle
class or a stroke attic families in this
country is that people from working
class backgrounds often know nothing
about their own origins they don't know
much more than two generations back they
might know their great-grandfather's
did you agree with me you know where as
you go to country house and their
ancestors are on the wall and people are
brought up knowing where they came from
or some version of it anyway and there's
a big thing that people are trying to
check out their ancestry and John's
doing in France so he's putting together
Mitri it's not much of a tree really
it's more like a shrub with a curious
blight in the roots than there but I
found some something very interesting
which was seven of our eight
great-grandparents you have eight seven
of them were all born in the middle of
19th century within two miles of each
other in the same part of local the same
parish that's how they met
I mean that's my version of how they met
I mean you might take a different you
say no no no the cosmos yeah so arrange
things that these eight soulmates would
converge in the same point of the
space-time continuum and meet each other
and fall in love and continue the
process that led to me being here that's
one version of it that's a possible
reading it's not the one I'm inclined to
I think people just have lower standards
then frankly you know I think good
people ran into each other machine
thought you will do no this is this is
not too embarrassing I could spend my
life with you without feeling socially
ostracized I don't think they were less
happy for it either by the way but they
weren't besieged by images on the
internet you know TMZ you know or Hello
magazine you know they didn't know that
Angelina Jolie was an option really and
waiting for Brad Pitt to show up in the
shop you know there's no you'll do other
thing is what something down an arm is
have existed if you think about your
lineage your um your personal lineage
you sitting here now if you think of the
number of people who had to meet each
other down the centuries and the certain
hands have had to come about for them to
meet each other however they did that
however they bumped into each other how
many people had to do that in how many
different circumstances and how many
different settings through the long
march of time till eventually your
parents met and under whatever
circumstances you were then conceived
and then now here you are
the Dalai Lama's point is to be born at
all is a miracle
it's a miracle that we're here and
congratulations bugger you made it where
billions didn't but here you are and you
made it and you're not here for long you
know with the following wind you've got
probably ninety Algiers which is the
blink of an eye in cosmic terms and his
comment was simply you didn't say this
in Vancouver he said it in a book he was
writing about meditation but he said to
be born at all as a miracle
so what are you going to do with this
life now that you have it what you're
going to do with it
you're going to waste it I'm going to do
something interesting with it you're
going to do something that matters to
you or not and this to me is where this
idea of passion comes in I published a
book last year I think you've got a copy
of it now if you have you paid for it
I don't see why I should summarize it if
haven't paid for it frankly a bit
who has paid for it I'll talk to you
privately they will go to the pump no
one things are struck me for a long time
is that very many people very many
people I'm not saying this is true of
you I don't know you know but you'll
know if it's true or you'll know if it's
true of people you know but very many
people spend their entire lives doing
things that aren't really careful they
just get through the week one way or
another they you know endure their lives
and wait for the weekend with no real
sense of fulfillment a kind of general
sense of tolerance for it or not and if
you want evidence for that you've only
got a look at the annual receipts of the
pharmaceutical companies and the brewing
companies you don't have to look at the
levels of crime and and of disengagement
I think of this is the the other climate
crisis you know we've become you see
idea that there is a crisis in the
world's natural resources that there is
I mean we needn't go into that now but
there was a group of geologists
published a report two years ago I mean
senior well-respected geologists and
they refer now they believe that for the
past 200 years geologically the planet
is in a new period called the
Anthropocene and they say that
geologists would recognize in the
geological record a distinct a new phase
since the last ice age if you just look
at the geological record they mean for
the first time in history a geological
age which is being caused by the
activities of human beings the
Anthropocene and he said you can see
that in carbon deposits in the
extinction of species in the changing
constitution of the oceans and of the
atmosphere human beings have made an
indelible geological imprint on the
planet and you know we don't know
frankly what the outcome of this is
likely to be but I think there's another
climate crisis which is a crisis which
is connected to it of human resources as
opposed to natural resource are in
addition
to natural resources what I mean is that
most people have no idea what they're
capable of
no real sense of their talents or their
abilities and met very many people
therefore conclude they don't have any
that there's nothing special about them
and my convictions always been to the
country that we're all born with deep
talents and abilities it if you're a
human being it comes with a kit I'm
convinced that the most distinctive
feature of human life is this power of
imagination I don't know how many of you
got animals or dogs but including dog
signs how you think I don't know what an
animal is animals or dogs
but if you take a small baby into the
garden preferably one that you know with
with the permission of whoever the
parent is if you run away with a small
baby and at night and point at the moon
the baby will look at the moon if you
take your dog into the garden and point
to the moon the dog will look at your
finger with an expression of irritation
in all probability and the difference is
that human beings are born with
expansive imaginations and a sense of
reference and possibility that we get
that we get that you can mean things you
know biologically were probably evolving
at the same rate as every other species
on earth but culturally we're in a
completely different category I mean if
you have a dog you know that culturally
they're not changing much are they
are they not really I mean if you don't
have to do checking in with dogs deer to
see what's new so what's the latest
thing with you people you know what are
you up to now pretty much what we're
always doing honestly is would you
choose me while I urinate on this chair
we've got past that Emily hello well
speaking personality but with human
beings there's always something new
where it was on to something because we
have not just this power of imagination
but what floats on which is the power of
creativity the ability to produce things
to make things to make new things and
we're all born with that like were born
with the power of language and and the
power of thought it comes with the kit
but some people discover their unique
and individual abilities and some don't
and those who don't often to conclude
they don't have any um the wood that I
also meet people who actually have found
what they think is their natural place
they their natural talents and they love
what they do and the lives that flow
from it they are to use that expression
they're in their element to be in the
element it been around has two things at
least one of them is you're doing
something for which you have a natural
capacity that you get it one of the
people that I include in the book is a
guy called Terence Tao and I mention him
because he's particularly gifted in
something I'm not good at which is
mathematics Terence is a mathematician
he works at UCLA in in Los Angeles when
I say is a mathematician he's actually
probably the most accomplished
mathematician on the planet he's known
as the Mozart of math there's no s in
mathematics in America's you know you'd
think it would be plural since was
mathematics with me Barry Terence when
he was three taught himself to read by
watching Sesame Street so he has a
rather curious accent
constants at the age of four he was
doing double-digit equations which I
still can't do at the age of eight he
took a college entrance math exam and
got 98% at the age of twenty got his PhD
in pure mathematics at the age of thirty
he was awarded the Fields Medal for
mathematics which is equivalent a Nobel
Prize it's reasonable to say isn't it
that Terrance gets math tennis got a
hang of this frankly it has a natural
aptitude for it something else I include
in the book was a woman called Ava
Lawrence but if you've had over Lawrence
Ava Lawrence I met on a plane and I
don't have told Terry about this yet but
anyway
as our in a public place I feel fairly
secure now and it helps to talk doesn't
it
actually truthfully I never speak to
people on aeroplanes
I fly a lot and I never speak to people
in opens if I can possibly avoid it
because you get trapped yeah I mean
you're on a plane for six hours and you
get trapped and do it with a perfect
stranger that and it may or may not be
interesting what if it's not you know I
mean I don't mind talking to people when
the plane lands
when we're taxing to the terminal I
would much rather regret the sex our
conversation we didn't have just met
than the one I have to put up with I was
on a flight
the Euro zero to Hong Kong from Los
Angeles and it's a 14-hour flight and as
the plane was boarding they hadn't
closed the door yet the guy next to me
you could tell he was bursting for a
conversation you can tell people fidget
and they and they're kind of clear their
throat and look at you and you think
he's going to ask me a question and I'm
doing everything I can to appear
socially unappealing and and I thought
what's it what's his line going to be
what is great opening going to be and it
came as the people were still mourning
it turned and he said so you going to
Hong Kong
I said yes that's why I'm on the Hong
Kong flame
in fact we're all going to Hong Kong
it's not just me by any means it's the
entire plane is going to Hong Kong speak
to them there are 500 of them okay like
busied myself in a book I was reading
Moby Dick eventually I got ran to Moby
Dick and and he waited for me so he said
so you're reading Moby Dick I said
excuse me I'm going to the toilet so I
did I went to the toilet and it's the
longest time I've ever spent in a toy
potentially fourteen hours altogether
and but I did finish Moby Dick you know
I was landing in this Besser on this
flight into Florida and there was a
woman sitting next to me and she's
beautiful woman in a forty time I think
she was and actually we got talking
which is she she asked me a question and
I imagined you know you do rap later I
don't know if she was in the media
something in the media no law or the
design industry or some I didn't know
and as to what she did and she's a
professional pool player you check her
out Eva Lawrence she's known as the
striking Viking she's from a small town
north of Stockholm John are in Stockholm
this week and when she was I think 12
she was following her brother round this
village I know that kids do they follow
their older siblings around and he
wandered into a pool hall and she said
she stopped at the door and she couldn't
believe what she was seeing I said what
she said it was like a Ladin's cave you
know it's fantastic is this dark space
and these pools of green light and
people bowed over these tables and it
was like church she said them in there
with this clicking of these balls and
beautifully colors beautiful colors
swirling around the green tables she
said there was so intense and she said
she sat there and transfer at two hours
and she worked out what they were doing
but they had to get the balls down in a
particular sequence and then she said it
the real breakthrough as I realized that
to use the white ball to do it so there
is an unbelievable and so she started
going regularly and she got the
Commission of her parents to go and she
went every evening that in fact they
knew the guy around the pool hole so he
let her use the office at the back to do
her homework after school then she could
practice for a couple of hours anyway
she went on to be the local champion she
took part in
regional championships she wants she
became Swedish national champion Women's
Champion she took part in the European
champions and won those and then she
moved to America this years later in
early twenties to the World
Championships where she lost and she
said I was kind of relieved in a way
because I thought the world's number one
would would be a lot better than I was
and she was anyway she set it then the
first women's pool league which is now
an international thing she runs
tournament she she gives master classes
she's written book she had her own TV
show she loves it and she said you know
I still when I go to the pool table I
don't know I couldn't tell you if I'd
been there for twenty minutes or three
hours I could show up lost in chat the
interesting to me was I couldn't stand
geometry at school but a particular
thing about geometry couldn't stand it I
couldn't get my head round it said but
pool is all geometry when the pool when
the balls move you just see new angles
opening up the new shapes and said I
actually used pool now to teach children
geometry the thing I didn't like and one
of the ways you know that you're in your
element is that your sense of time
changes you know if you're doing things
you don't like an hour five minutes
feels like an hour if you're doing
things you love to do an hour feels like
five minutes and this is the other
element so to speak of the element but
one of them is aptitude but the other is
passion it's not enough to be good at
something to be in your element I know
lots of people who do things they're
good at that they don't like they're
just good at it one of the stab rook in
the early 80s called the arts in schools
and know if any of you know this book
but it was with the Gulbenkian
foundation we had a brilliant editor on
the book called Millicent and asked her
one day over and said how long have been
an editor he said about five years now
well she was in their late thirties at
that point so I said well what we're
doing before said I was a concert
pianist I said what happened
bit of a segue isn't it by the way this
happens doesn't it we're being brought
up with this idea that life is linear
haven't we this is an idea this is
perpetuated when you come to write your
CV now that you set out your life in a
series of dates and achievements in a
linear way you know as if your whole
existence has progressed in an ordered
structured way to bring you to this
current interview who are having at the
moment and it all gives the impression
that were in control of what we're doing
and that our life was not the random
series of chaotic events that that you
don't want to present to a prospective
employer did you know my life was a mess
right until now frankly I mean I look at
my CV occasion I think I didn't plan
this I didn't I mean I didn't think when
I was walking to the 4-square temple in
Liverpool if it all goes well you know
one day I'll be at the Conway hole you
know talking at the School of Life you
know you don't plan things like that do
you I mean you you take opportunities
and you respond to them but you take
them more willingly if they correspond
to your own attitudes and sensibilities
so I said to Millicent I say Leah why
had you take this well trodden path from
being a concert pianist to being a book
editor and she said what happened was
she was giving a concert at the in the
Purcell room on the south bank and at
the end of the concert she went off for
dinner with the conductor and the
conductor said you were brilliant
tonight Millicent and she said well
thank you very much and there was pause
and then she said he said but you didn't
enjoy it to do
she said enjoy what so that the
performance she said no no not
especially he said do you enjoy it she
said what performing said yeah I said no
not really
I suppose not ready he said why do you
do it then and she said well I suppose
because I'm good at it and he said you
know being good at something isn't a
good enough reason to do it not to spend
your life doing it and she realized what
happened was that she'd been born into a
musical family she'd shown a talent
she taken all that guild all exams she'd
gone to a musically based school she
went to the Royal College of Music where
should a music degree and then she did a
doctor music degree and then she'll as
the night follows the day I progressed
on to the concept platform in my
mid-twenties and nobody stopped to ask
me if I wanted to do it and she said I
didn't ask myself I just took it for
granted that that's what my life was
going to be I said it was only when he
asked me that that I realized that I
didn't like it my whole life she said
the thing that I've loved to do is books
I love reading books I love writers I
love being with writers I love the
literary culture and she said I I
crammed him wherever I could but I never
thought that was an available life for
me and I decided there and then that I
was going to do the thing I wanted to do
and said at the end of that season I
closed the piano lid and I've never
opened it since and I've lived in the
world I want to be in I've been writing
when working on books she had never been
happier
never poorer but never happier and
that's the thing that being any relevant
doesn't necessarily entail financial
riches but it does offer you a much
surer guarantee of some sort of
spiritual fulfillment and I use the word
spiritual advisedly when I say I have
some reservations are organized religion
that's just a personal thing but not
about spiritual things and what I mean
by spirit is that sense of what animates
your life now we use this term all the
time in everyday life we talk about
being in high spirits or low spirits we
talk about being lifted up or down if
you're in your element doing whatever it
is that you love to do then at the end
of the day or the end of the week you
can be physically exhausted by it but
spiritually uplifted but if you're doing
things you don't care for at the end of
the day you can feel physically fine but
down and needing to lift yourself up
again and in the end it's about energy
that's all life is isn't it it's about
energy it's what stirs your energy what
encourages it what fuels it and what
takes it from you and I find that if
you're doing things that you love to do
if you're in your element if you're
following a passion of some sort that
you get energy from some activities take
it from you don't they you change you're
like doing something you feel
that it's drained you but I see people
doing things they love to do and their
energy levels have risen because of it
because they take energy from the
activity it doesn't drain their energy
and since life is essentially energy it
seems to me rather important that we try
to pursue those things for ourselves and
the book is about that and it's also
about the importance of creating the
conditions under which that will happen
when I talk about there being another
climate crisis I think it's because so
many people have denied themselves that
possibility now it doesn't follow that
you know what this is in your case I
know a lot of people have stumbled
across the things they love to do and
have taken the opportunity when it's
arisen other times they've been helped
by other people have seen their talent
before they saw it in almost every case
there are Mentors
some doubt there who supported and
helped you one of the people in the book
just a final example is a guy called
Bart Connor if you heard about Connor
Bart Connor lives in Norman Oklahoma I
do a lot of work in Oklahoma these days
and on this creativity mischief that's
happening across the state when Bart was
six he discovered that he could walk at
his hands as easily as he could walk on
his feet now we don't know how he
discovered this but he did and he said
it wasn't much use you know but he was
in demand socially and
he said you know whenever there's a
party at the house and the conversation
stalled you know his dad would say Bart
just do the hands they go very with you
and the conversation would pick up again
and then he found he could walk up and
down stairs on his hands as easy as on
his feet he's done it for me and it's a
longer story I can't go into it anyway
here but nobody thought much about at
this it was just Bart party trick but
his mother did and when he was eight he
said his mother spoke to the school he
was at and with the school's permission
took him downtown in Morton Grove
Illinois to the local gymnastic Center
and he said I'll never forget the
feeling when I walked into this
gymnasium
I said why he said it was like a mixture
of Santa's grotto and Disneyland said
really he said yes it was intoxicating
intoxicating I said why what way he said
well there were wall bars there were
ropes there were trampolines mats so it
was intoxicating well is that how you
feel when you walk into gymnasium is it
looking around not everybody I feel has
this feeling funny in toxic I don't I
don't find it intoxicating to in a
gymnasium on the country I need to get
intoxicated if I if I get within 50
yards of a gymnasium hey he went in and
he started going every day because it
was something he could do and he loved
it
ten years later he walked onto the mat
at the Montreal Olympics represent
United States in the male gymnastics
squad he went on to be the most
decorated male gymnasts in American
history he lives now in Norman Oklahoma
he's married to Nadia common edge
remember she was the first perfect ten
in women's gymnastics they have a
wonderful little boy called given after
Bob Dylan why not Bob
we don't know it's it's what comes to
spending your life upside down probably
he and Nadia have their own gymnastics
center they're leading members the
world's Special Olympics movement so
between them that helped to liberate the
gymnastic capabilities of thousands and
thousands of athletes with special needs
now just two quick points about this the
first is that Bart's mother could have
said about stop it with the hands thing
today when it was six
you know we get it
we get it you can do it now get over it
get on with your homework
do what you meant to do but she didn't
she couraged him and because of that he
let went on to have this extraordinary
life but the other point is that even
though she encouraged him she couldn't
have known the journey he was about to
take she couldn't have anticipated it
could she because life is not like that
it's not linear when you follow your
interest when you connect with your own
true energy your life takes a different
path new people come into it a new
opportunity created you affect their
lives and they affect your lives it's a
a process of reciprocity something
Joseph Campbell said I mean his
expression is about following your bliss
but he means the same thing essentially
which is if you do that opportunities
open up that weren't there before and
other people wouldn't have had because
this is your life that's opening up you
know I'm sure that Bart's mother didn't
think you know here's Bart he's six it
can do this Hammes thing there's this
girl in Romania
I believe you know and I have a Bob
Dylan album it's a natural it's a
natural
and the reason is that we create our own
liars we create it for ourselves it's
the gift of human life that you're not
committed to a single course you can
change course you can create and you can
recreate your life and you're more
likely to do that if you tap into the
thing that you find motivation
fulfilling than not because in the end
it's simply that it's about energy it's
um the last example this is my our son
went to the University of Southern
California and it's interesting because
that it's quite an expensive place and
on the first day Terry and I went along
and all the new students were taken off
for their academic briefing and we were
taken off to the finance department
for a form of grief counseling and we
just spent the afternoon tearing up
checks till it didn't hurt us anymore
and but one of the professor's they gave
a great talk he said know now that your
kids are here
leave them alone they'll spare them your
advice if you can he said because you
don't know what they'll discover about
themselves while they're here and they
said he gave the example was out on some
he said when his son would start at USC
- about 12 years before ten or twelve
years before he said he was planning to
do
classics he's going to major in classics
and he said we're a bit worried about
that because we walked for what type of
a job would you get with a classics
degree he said so we're really relieved
when at the end of the first year of
college he came home and said you know
mum and dad and think I don't think I'll
do classics as a main as a major he said
okay trying to suppress our enthusiasm
for this decision isn't great is it why
is that he said honestly I don't think
it's gonna be very practical it's all
right okay said so I think I'm gonna do
something else that be more useful he
said great what's that he said
philosophy and
they said so we pointed out that none
the big philosophy companies were hiring
at the moment the job market was a bit
sluggish in philosophy and he said
anyway he went back and he did the years
philosophy but he ended up majoring in
art history he said never tell you that
here we are ten years later he has a job
in a major auction house he travels the
world he makes good money but enough for
himself he loves the life he leads and
the people he leads it with and you know
he couldn't be feeling better about how
this has turned out and he said the
reason he got the job was because of his
knowledge of art history
his grounding in ancient cultures and
the intellectual training that came with
his philosophy program he said but if
he'd gone into USC and we'd said him no
here's the plan why don't you do
philosophy art history and classics and
you never know ten years now there may
be a job in an auction house you know it
could just line up that way
and they say it isn't that way because
of the essentially creative nature of
being alive of being a human being and
to me it's an essential principle it's
why I argue so hard about reform in
education because our education systems
are based on a linear mode of production
and it's I believe why so many people
end up feeling detached from their own
talents because they've been through an
education system that prioritizes
certain types of talent and marginalizes
the vast majority of other ones and if
you're not good at certain things like
if you're not good at mathematics
you're assumed not to be good generally
and for me it's why we have to argue for
a transformation education systems are
not just that but also in our workplaces
but it begins the transformation of
ourselves it's something that we came
the view that came we came to the
Vancouver peace summit
was that you can't the summit the Dalai
Lama said you cannot promote world peace
if you are angry it's as simple as that
it's Gandhi's point you have to be at
peace with yourself not complacent with
yourself but at least at peace with your
own possibilities and as Gandhi said you
have to be the change you want to see in
the world you can't promote things which
you are into which you are insensitive
it's why so many teachers have a problem
protein creativity because they
themselves aren't in touch with their
own creative possibilities and why
that's a bigger hill that we have to
climb but in the end I think it comes
back to what Carl Jung said he said that
I am NOT what has happened to me as a
human being I am what I choose to become
it's the same point George Kelly made
when he said that nobody needs to be the
victim of their own biography and as
Jung said you're what we choose to
become and as a human being you're born
with a lot of choices and I think for
our own fulfillment for the footprint of
the people around us we should be sure
to explore them and make the right one
thank